um
um
the other side okay probably yes
okay so uh first let me thank the
organizers for putting this together i'm
quite happy to see like real faces here
um after a long time i'm sure
our friends across the pond have the
same feeling so um
uh it's quite good action that i don't
have to do a lot of intro
over the some of the intros so i'll try
to be quick on that because here there
are two kinds of papers that i want to
speak about and uh so uh let's see if
it's speaking on time uh so first before
starting about the title is a title that
actually i borrowed from a blog post
from sulu
uh where she was discussing in 2018 some
of these new applications of generative
models uh to regularize inverse problems
and what it was very cool title and she
was asking
okay are these generative models uh the
new sparsity and uh actually this talk
aims at answering this question at least
in some toy models where we have control
over uh everything like uh like in the
case that flour was presenting so these
are um my collaborators into these two
uh works that i'm gonna present today uh
some friends from uh from paris and uh
here uh etfl
uh
so just before starting with the actual
problem i just want to make sure the
setup is clear for everyone so uh here
we are doing a uh inference or a
trendy solos inverse problem we have a
signal this signal has been generated
through some distribution has been sent
to the statistician for some channel and
uh the survey and the statistician
observes the the the corrupted version
of the signal and wants to actually gets
back uh the signal that was generated
and actually you're gonna be always
working in in in this talk on the base
optimal setting where actually uh the
statistician knows everything about the
process that has corrupted the signal
and distribution that has generated the
signal uh she just doesn't know uh the
specific realization of the signal so
it's about recovering this specific
realization so it's a planted
satin-based optimal inference problem
and what are the questions we are
interested in answering in this sort of
problems is um how many samples actually
the statistician needs to actually
recover the specific realization um
actually how to do this in practice or
which kind of algorithm
she can use actually to recover the
signal and uh given these few questions
what is the role of the structure or the
prior distribution that the statistician
has
in in the recovery so different
different structures you might imagine
that
might lead to different uh types of
algorithms to reconstruction
so uh here are some of the archetypical
examples of of problems that fit this
general framework that i just introduced
to have denoising major saturization
that's exactly what flour was speaking
about and we have two other very
celebrated problems like uh compressed
sensing and it's causing phase retrieval
uh where actually the signal is
compressed uh by by multiplying by a
matrix corrupted and then in the phase
retrieval we also lose the information
about uh the face
okay so
people have studied a lot these kind of
problems in the past years and a lot of
the works have focused uh on the third
question on structure in a simple model
of sparse signals so we know that many
kind of a class of signals admit uh
sparsing coding in some basis so we can
think about sound uh in fourier we can
think about images in waves like bases
and uh therefore you would imagine in
principle that okay since i know the
distribution of the signal the fact that
there are many zeros on my signal i have
less information to recover so it's
going to be easy but actually because of
the combinatorial problem of finding all
the zeros often sparsity uh reflects in
some algorithmic difficulty because
actually uh uh it's very hard to find
the exact configuration of this zero so
um not always we can leverage these uh
this uh this advantage of star signals
in terms of algorithms so um
we in this work we wanted to ask the
question in terms of how does the
sparsity and all these works that have
studied these parses in these problems
that i have introduced how do they
compare to other kind of encodings and
specifically this kind of a generative
encoding generating neural network
encoding uh that people have been
looking in practice uh since 2017. so uh
in particular we are thinking here about
uh neural networks so your signal
actually being sampled from a trained
neural network
and uh we know that you know
neural networks are able to do amazing
things for example they are able to
represent uh uh to learn the
distribution of realistic images from a
latent representation that is just
gaussian noise so uh
at least in our mind what we're trying
to do is the following
imagine
that someone
somewhere has trained in a huge data set
with a lot of computational uh power has
trained a generative network to actually
represent
some class of signals that you are
interested let's say images so someone
has a lot of computational power has
strengthened your network has uploaded
on github
the statistician
is going to get
this new network has been trained that
presumably uh understands well what is
an image and what is not an image and
we are trying to ask the question can we
use this knowledge that has been learned
by the neural network to actually
perform better interference or to
regularize these inverse problems so
that's kind of the setting uh um that we
have in mind so actually this signal has
been uh generated from this neural
network the person who is performing
interference knows that has the weights
of this neural networks and we are
trying to ask
whether she can use these weights to
actually uh uh infer better
okay
so that's for the setting
um
and here i'm gonna try to answer this
question in a very simple model which is
the model that flour was speaking about
actually a simple version because here
we don't have a tensor plus a matrix we
just have a matrix uh so that's the
matrix factorization problem
actually my signal is drawn from a
distribution can be a sparse one or in
the case that i'm going to be interested
these generative networks
then you perform the tensor product of
the signal with itself so we produce a
matrix
you add some gaussian noise additive
gaussian noise and the statistician is
observing uh this uh p by p matrix which
is the tensor or the matrix corrupted by
some some gaussian noise
okay and the goal is going to be to
reconstruct x star from the knowledge of
the distribution of the signal
the noise level that i have introduced
and it's in particular going to be
interested in high dimensional limit
where the dimension is going to infinite
so it's very hard to sample from the
posterior uh that you could in principle
think uh as an algorithm knowing the
information of how the signal uh uh was
corrupted um and the noise level is
going to be of uh order constant
okay
so um what is known about this problem
in the sparse case so now we consider a
very uh toy model for a sparse signal
where we have a mix between some
gaussian components and some zero and
here i have a density row uh of non-zero
components so when rho is equal to one
um
i have just n just a gaussian when rho
is equal to zero i have just zeros so um
this is a plot from uh from a work by uh
and uh lincoln
where uh they have shown that uh for
this problem where uh amp the algorithm
that was speaking about uh is the best
known polynomial time algorithm for this
problem they have shown that actually
there is exactly this phenomena that i
was describing before there is exactly
this
problem that
for certain sparsity levels
amp is not able to reach
the statistical optimal performance so
there is this hard phase so this figure
has a lot of information but i'm just
putting here pictorially what is going
on so here you have um
the performance also the msc of the
algorithm compared to the uh
to the msc
of the statistical optimal uh estimator
which is the bayesian uh estimator for
this problem because we have all
information about how the signal was
generated and how it was corrupted and
we have this hard phase here that uh
actually where amp is getting stuck
so the question you want to ask is
okay
if now i change the distribution of the
signal instead of having star signal i
have
a neural network
of that l
and here uh that's important we are
going to focus on the case where the
weights are are random gaussian render
matrices so we are not considered the
trained case which would be of course
what we would like to do but uh so far
we only know how to do
the analysis for the running case
the question is
given that the signal is is sampled from
these uh from this neural network and
given the knowledge of of this
distribution
can we actually make better like uh make
better inference than in the sparse case
okay so this is exactly the same theorem
that
show to you but in a more vanilla case
because again we don't have the tensor
actually in this high dimensional limit
we managed to characterize exactly what
is the mmsc for this problem so the
error uh achieved by the
statistically optimal estimator for the
problem and actually in the high
dimensional limit this is characterized
by minimizing a certain function uh this
potential this potential is given in
terms of
information uh between the signal and a
corrupted version and actually we are
quite lucky because uh before us uh some
other people have computed this mutual
information density so uh when it exists
our theorem gives the performance of the
of the of the bayesian estimator and uh
some people have shown both rigorous and
uh and uh for two layers but uh also
have computed aeolistically for more
layers uh
what is this mutual information is so we
can just read these works uh plug in our
formula and characterize the performance
of the bayesian estimator uh for this
kind of uh prior
and these are some curves of how it
looks like the performance of the
beijing estimator and uh here we cover
some
expected uh uh behavior that for example
for different architectures increasing
the depth of these networks like it's
easier and easier to recover the signal
because you're having more information
but of course the question we are really
interested here is not the performance
of the bayesian estimator but how does
an algorithm compare with that like so
can i find an algorithm that actually
can leverage a disadvantage
in terms of actually a
computational power
okay
so
as snp is the best uh algorithm we know
for the sparse case uh actually we are
we are also going to look into mp in
this case uh and actually mp has this
very nice property that uh it's very
easy to compose it so once you have one
block of amp let's say once you have one
layer of adp here for the spike uh here
for the spike uh problem and you have
another block of amp for uh the
generalized linear estimation so here
i've just considered one layer of
generative prior it's actually very easy
to go
and compose it together and have an amp
for the composed system as long as we
are based optimally in what we're doing
it's very easy to write down this
algorithm
for the compose system and actually you
can iterate this as much as you want you
want to put another layer you put
another layer and so on and uh there is
a very well defined prescription to do
that
so it's a very uh friendly algorithm for
this reason
so here is how the algorithm looks looks
like for one layer generative prior so
yeah if you know mp
like this is gonna ring a bell if you
don't uh is like kind of a beast uh so
my my goal is not to describe how this
works but it's just an algorithm
iterative algorithm which is uh
first uh first order so just multiplying
by matrices and then applying some uh
some scalar functions and it produces an
estimate of the marginals of the
posterior distribution so that's all you
need to know uh uh need to know about
the amp if you haven't seen it before
and actually you don't even need to code
it because uh some
very uh uh
very uh uh good people uh have actually
implemented a package where actually you
can just just like you do in part tour
to do like import and then you add one
layer and then you add one another layer
as long as you are composing a tree of
different amps
the package can handle it so and also if
you have an inference problem which you
are interested and you know how to write
amp for this influence problem for this
likelihood then you can just go there
and put there and compose with the ones
that are already implemented so it's a
very uh compositional uh
friendly uh
algorithm and this package implements it
so you don't even need to code it
and so now the question is
given that you have an algorithm and
given that you have the statistical
optimal performance how do they compare
is there a gap just like for the sparse
case
and
for our surprise
actually
for this problem there is no gap
actually a amp
is able to achieve the statistical
optimal performance for many of the
architect for many of the natural uh
generative architectures you can think
so just choose your favorite activation
function like relu compose many relu
together
in a multi-layer structure
and uh
actually compute the bayesian optimal uh
performance
and
and running in b and you're going to see
that they agree so amp is able to
leverage all this knowledge of the prior
to achieve the optimal performance so
there is no statistical problem getting
this problem
so this analysis is in the in the
asymptotic limit but also there has been
a follow-up works to ours who have shown
that this conclusion holds true also in
the non-asymptotic one and i think uh
probably pohan maybe might speak about
that uh uh i think
on friday i don't know today actually
today later on uh in berkeley so uh yeah
so i'm interested uh
he's gonna probably present about that
after
okay
another cool thing about amp is that it
not only provides like this algorithm
that we can achieve the optimal
performance but it's very
easy for mp to get a spectral method
that is just comparable to to like pca
so in this problem
uh if you didn't know anything about the
information of the prior the natural
thing you would do is just you take your
matrix you take your spike matrix
uh you take the leading eigenvector and
use this as an estimate of your signal
and if the prior is gaussian then this
is a very good thing to do but if your
prior is like a generative network or
sparse actually you're not leveraging
the knowledge of the prior heaven pca is
not going to do very well in the steps
however we were able to get our amp
linearize it will obtain a spectral
method that comes from it which we call
the l amp or lump
linear amp
which does a very similar thing to pca
so it takes the leading eigenvector
of one matrix but not the spike matrix
now it is a modified matrix that
actually depends on the population
covariance of the distribution
of the of the signal that you're trying
to estimate of the spike and actually
for a single layer you can actually
compute what this population matrix is
depends on the weights of the generative
network
but it's quite cute because it gives a
very out of the box way of of estimating
your signal taking into account the
structure that is encoded into this
matrix scale
the population covariance
okay
and if you plot the performance of this
algorithm uh uh against uh pca and i
guess the optimal bayesian estimator
is quite it's quite good because you can
see here that lump which is the green
dots
actually correlate with the signal at
the same
threshold noise threshold as amp
so of course the performance is worse
because the linearized version of the mp
but it correlates with the signal at the
same threshold so it's quite good
and in particular it beats pc8 which
starts correlating with the signal
always at one
so uh we can also improve over pca using
uh this linearized version of amp which
is easy to uh easy to code and to run
and actually
an idea that we had is even like okay
let's give a try this algorithm and try
in a distribution of signals that we
don't even know uh where they come from
let's try like some real images and
estimate this covariance matrix just by
the empirical covariance
of the signal over the data set that we
have and you can see that even in this
task like this the
linearized version of the amp is able to
correlate with the true signal um
at a nice level which is much higher
than pca so that's kind of a
it's kind of a cool application
okay
so
that was about it for uh despite matrix
model and what i want to do in the last
seven minutes that i have is to talk to
you about another problem so of course
when we had this conclusion that we were
like quite surprised that actually uh um
that actually uh generative priors for
the spike matrix factorization problem
but didn't have this computational
statistical gap uh we said okay we need
we need to try harder problems problems
that have bigger uh
notably bigger gaps
so uh
we went for uh for two problems like
which is a phase retrieval and
compressed sensing and in particular
phase retrieval
is a problem that we know that has a
particularly big gap i'm going to show
to you so just before to recap again
what these models are like both of them
can be written down as a generalized
linear estimation problem you have a
signal drawn from a distribution you
apply a matrix usually a compressive
um
then you apply a non-linear activation
component wise this can be the modulus
for the phase retrieval or can be
whatever you want but okay for the
compressed sensor it's just a linear
function and then the suspicion is
observing uh
the the result of that and you can also
add noise on this process so here i i
wrote the noiseless version but of
course you can add another
additive gaussian noise
okay and the goal is the same we want to
reconstruct the signal given the
distribution
give it a sensing matrix a
activation function uh sigma
and oh actually here phi
and uh we want to do this in the high
dimensional limit where the number of
samples and the dimension go to infinity
while the ratio is kept of order one
okay
so uh this is the phase diagram uh from
uh worker by jean barbier uh lenka from
that uh
characterize
the the phase diagram for uh the stars
uh for the sparse version of phase
retrieval and uh what i want you to pay
attention in this phase diagram is that
even when
rho goes to zero
which means
that it has a very very sparse signal
and remember the statistician knows that
so she knows that there are
almost all the signal is zero even in
this case you still have
a
statistical computational gap respect to
a and b
and uh
just a a
a comment about this region which will
not be interested uh for us uh in this
talk but uh recently
has been some work by uh by some
colleagues that are showing that
actually uh in this point where actually
just have a gaussian signal uh this gap
they built a
normal time algorithm that actually can
achieve a better performance than mp
which is quite cool but uh okay that's
that's uh that's for uh for another time
now we want to focus more on the stars
region of this phase diagram
okay
so
uh here you can do the same analysis
that we did before we can compute
the statistical performance so you can
compute the performance of the base
optimal estimator
we can run build an amp for this problem
and
this amp we can put as many layers as we
want just like uh we did for the for the
spike uh case and then we can just plot
what amp house amp performing in
comparison to uh to the statistical
optimal performance and uh okay so the
conclusion here
is that even in the generative case we
are observing these hard phases so
remember these are phases in which uh
amp is not correlating uh to the signal
but statistically you have enough
information to recover the signal so
actually there is these uh these uh
these gaps here you see that as you
increase the depth of your generative
network this gap is getting smaller and
smaller
and actually we can plot a phase diagram
just like we had for the sparse case and
here i'm leaving uh this line here for
comparison is the line of the star stage
uh as you remember even when rho goes to
zero uh we had this uh this gap between
the performance of the amp and
the bayesian estimator
and uh and
in green red and yellow i'm plotting uh
respect to the generative project so
green means that the problem is easy so
actually amp is able to recover the
signal uh exactly so yellow is a hard
phase it's exactly when amp fails but
you have enough information
statistically to recover your signal and
red is the impossible region is that
like statistically even if you had
exponential time you wouldn't be able to
recover uh correlated with your signal
so
as you can see
the generative price for this model
uh is able to outperform
uh
the case uh where you match the
compression rate of your prior
with the sparsity level of the of the
stars prior and uh in particular the
hard phase which is out what what is
interesting us and what is the topic of
this workshop it's much smaller and this
is for one layer generative prior but we
can iterate this for more and more
layers and this phase this hard phase
asymptotically disappears so it doesn't
disappear
for a finite number of layers but you
get a very very small uh hard face
and that's for the phase retrieval i
think more or less the same conclusion
holds for the compressed sensing i
didn't put the phrase diagram here
but uh for the for the compressed
sensing which is an easier problem the
heart phase is smaller and also for the
generative prior is smaller than in the
sparse case
okay
um
so
as i was saying giant friars have a
smaller algorithm gap and that actually
goes into the direction of another work
by uh by a forehands group
which
viewed an algorithm uh suggesting this
as well it's not amp
but it goes in the same direction
okay
to conclude uh
i have argued that generative prizes
have comparatively smaller algorithmic
gaps in their sparse counterparts at
least in this set of archetypical random
toy models for inference problems uh and
i have showed that our reading gap can
be reduced with both that and also with
the compression of the signal
so really uh going back to soledad's
question uh i want just to leave a
provocation actually alternative price
the new sparsity or are they better than
sparsity so in this context we can say
that they seem to be at least
algorithmically more advantageous than
sparsity and of course this question uh
doesn't say anything about a real life
application so that uh i leave for uh
for our engineering friends uh to
actually uh
uh go back to this question and actually
uh apply problems okay with that i would
like to thank you for the attention and
these are the archive links for the two
papers that i have covered here
thanks
yes
[Music]
it feels to me that what's happening is
the top of the spectrum of the old all
the matrix of the weights is giving a
certain bias for you to be you know the
covariance is going to have a high end
value there
and so if you had a random orthogonal
matrices instead of gaussian matrices
this shouldn't happen and then the fire
maybe doesn't say anything so is it is
the problem a lot harder if you have
like if you replace with orthogonal
matrices instead of gaussian matrix
like do you see a difference or do you
have any intuition oh
i mean we didn't write it but i think it
can be done with orthogonal matrices uh
i mean we definitely can we definitely
can do a target matrix for one block and
the argument here is that uh all these
methods are both from the amp or for the
computation of the base optimal
estimator uh what you have learned in
the past few years that it's quite easy
to compose them that's what i showed in
this compositional principle so i'm i
i'm pretty sure we can do for the
orthogonal matrices as well and uh
yeah we did that
okay ah for the for the yeah but yeah
that is true so
yeah actually uh this this has been done
for the case where you have the
composition of many uh glms
and uh what was the conclusion
that you can do
you can do it but in terms of the
directions does the fire tell you
anything
because there's two things in the fire
there's the real use and there's the
fact that it's pushing you towards the
the directions of higher values of
trouble
it's just
it can be done like a method
but you couldn't
you should look at because if the
formula is there
because if you take away the real lose
all you're doing is you're biasing for
certain directions and then it makes
sense that ionization is the covariance
for the for the spectrum method you see
in the in the spiked version
yeah i mean we
we don't we don't we don't have the
spiked version for that for with the
autonomous matrices but uh i mean as i
said the team holds this move to
information we have the information so
it's just a question of plugging and uh
and checking uh
so we had a break scheduled but since
we're behind schedule do you want to
move ahead with the next speaker
is that good with you guys in europe
it's up to you bros is fine
great so we're very excited to have guy
braziler here telling us about
reductions
great um
at least not yet yeah if it goes all
right you can
consider clapping at the end um
yeah so it's uh just wonderful to be
here presenting at this workshop i
really enjoyed hearing people's
new work and ideas and things
so i'm going to tell you about
reductions as alex said and
the primary aim of this talk is to maybe
try to demystify a little bit
of some of these ideas to take some of
the magic out of these ideas if they've
seemed sort of unapproachable
and
maybe the reason for this is because
there's a sort of folklore in
complexity theory that average case
reductions in particular are really
challenging and so we learned this sort
of from the beginning and i remember
taking complexity courses and being told
like all right average case reductions
you don't want to go there i mean
there's been this 11 stuff that's really
nice but we haven't made a whole lot of
progress since then and so
um
the primary maybe aim of this talk is to
convince you that we should be
optimistic about this direction in
general
um all right
um
so uh yeah with that said it'll be a
little bit tutorial in nature so feel
free to interrupt with some quick
question i might have forgotten to
explain something some notation whatever
um don't hesitate to just ask
all right so this is joint work with um
matt brennan and as uh
many of you know
matt suddenly passed away earlier this
year